toll dass sie dabei sind wir haben
wieder viel zu reden das virus ist
nämlich da angekommen wieder da
angekommen wo wir es gar nicht hin haben
wollten und wo es am gefährlichsten ist
in den seniorenheimen nämlich
seniorenheim in schorfheide in
brandenburg zwölf bewohner sind hier an
corona gestorben trotz doppelter impfung
fast alle waren über 80 und hatten
vorerkrankungen von den mitarbeitern ist
nur die hälfte geimpft einer hatte das
heim trotz eines positiven corona tests
betreten auch in einem altenheim im
kreis salzwedel sind vier bewohner
gestorben auch hier sind viele
mitarbeiter ungeimpft bei den älteren
gibt es mehr und mehr im durch brüche
knapp 44 prozent der kurve patienten die
ins krankenhaus müssen sind doppelt
geimpft von den cupid patienten auf den
intensivstationen sind 33 prozent
doppelt geimpft
über 60 jährige christine fall 33
prozent auf den intensivstationen
dachten besonders gut geschützt zu sein
mit dieser doppelten impfung und sie
sind es nicht oder sie sind es nicht
mehr müssen wir noch mal erklären wie
kann das passieren und so schnell also
die allermeisten menschen über 60 und
unter 60 die zwei impfungen bekommen
haben sind ja sehr gut geschützt wir
haben 55 millionen menschen doppelt
geimpft und wir haben
145.000 impf durchbrüche das ist also
weit unter 1 prozent 0,02 ungefähr das
heißt die meisten menschen sind nach wie
vor sehr gut geschützt aber wir wissen
eben dass das immunsystem individuell
ein bisschen mehr oder ein bisschen
weniger gut auf diese impfung reagiert
und mit der zeit kann das etwas abnehmen
das ist weder ungewöhnlich noch
beunruhigend aber wenn diese menschen im
krankenhaus oder eben in einem altenheim
dann ein höheres risiko haben dass es
doch ein bisschen schneller absinkt sind
dass die menschen die gefährdet sind das
ist zwar ein kleiner prozentsatz aber
der ist eben besonders gefährdet wenn er
in einer umgebung es in der virus
vorhanden ist und wie wird das virus
sozusagen weiter verbreitet durch die
ungeimpften die sich mischen mit denen
man deren impfschutz eben nicht mehr
ganz so perfekt ist und dann entsteht
dieses risiko muss man auch einmal
erklären wird ja häufig diskutiert
manche interpretieren dass also als ein
versagen des impfstoffes was es
definitiv nicht ist sondern es sind die
ungeimpften die im grunde dafür sorgen
dass das virus so virulent also die
exzellent diese impfstoffe sind sieht
man daran dass alle menschen zwischen
zwölf jahren und egal ins hohe alter
antikörper machen und t-zellen unsere
beiden superwaffen die wir da haben und
das gilt für alle menschen die doppelt
geimpft sind und deswegen ist der
impfstoff extrem wirksam bei wenigen
menschen nimmt es halt ein bisschen
früher ab dieser komplette schutz und
wir merken bei diesem virus die data
variante der darf man sozusagen kein
millimeter raum lassen sonst schafft es
sie doch durch diese abwehr die wieder
haben durch den impfschutz in den
nasen-rachen-raum zu kommen und menschen
zu infizieren also der impfschutz ist
extrem gut und die wenigen menschen die
ein höheres risiko haben die über
70-jährigen und auch andere können wir
noch darüber sprechen wir machen die
muskeln sagt die chefin von der
deutschen gesellschaft für immunologie
bei uns ist zugeschaltet aus düsseldorf
andreas gassen er ist vorsitzender der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
natürlich vergessen das ist vor allen
dingen bei alten menschen im durchbrüche
geben würde die frau falk jetzt nochmal
und erklärt hat das ist ja nichts
unbekanntes gewesen damit konnte man
rechnen warum glauben sie ist man jetzt
doch so überrascht dass auch wir diese
fälle haben in deutschland
ich weiß nicht ob er wirklich überrascht
sind es ist natürlich immer traurig und
schockiert die menschen wenn dann trotz
einer impfung mit dem man sich
vermeintlich hundertprozentig sicher
fühlt dass der impfschutz sich 100
prozent sein würde wussten wir immer und
dann passiert sowas trotzdem nur ist es
ja so ich glaube wir sollten auch
versuchen da ein bisschen ruhe
reinzubekommen natürlich wir wissen
jetzt diese menschen brauchen eine
auffrischimpfung eine dritte impfung das
können wir auch leisten
damit haben ja auch wieder ein wirksamer
schutz und können diese
bevölkerungsgruppe dann wieder wirksam
schützen dass sie so geschützt sind wie
die anderen und ich glaube ganz wichtig
ist das volk hat das heute morgen auch
sehr schöne ministeriumsprecher es ist
ja nicht so dass der impfschutz wie bei
einem ist ein zeitschriften abo wenn das
ausläuft am nächsten tag verschwunden
ist der wird dann graduell weniger
insofern sollten wir uns natürlich
beeilen aber es ist auch nicht so dass
das wir nur noch wenige tage zeit haben
aber natürlich je eher wir jetzt
beginnen umso besser ist das umso
wichtiger bei auch heute dass wir uns
darauf verständigt haben wo wir den
schwerpunkt dieser auffrischimpfung
gegen wohl nicht ich sondern das ja
schon getan ja sie sind schon bei der
auffrischimpfung ich wollte noch mal
verstehen und der zuschauer will ist
natürlich ob das verstehen was da
passiert karl lauterbach ist bei uns
gesundheitspolitiker von der spd herr
lauterbach diesen brandenburger fall mit
den elf toten prüfen jetzt die behörden
aber es gibt nicht nur diesen fall in
brandenburg es gibt einen genauso schwer
wiegenden in mecklenburg vorpommern es
gibt ihn in hamburg und es gibt ihn in
anderen fällen in anderen städten
entschuldigung es ist also nicht nur
dieser bedauerlicher einzelfall wofür
steht das in ihren augen das steht für
ein system also wir haben das problem
die studien zeigen im zweier leider ist
also die antikörper menge die im körper
nachzuweisen ist nach den impfungen
schneller sinkt bei älteren menschen
geht schneller zurück das zweite was wir
wissen dass wir auch noch eine ganze
zeit lang unklar das risiko dass man
sich infiziert hängt davon ab wie viele
antikörper man hat es gibt ja auch noch
andere also ab hört man schon ist man
die t-zellen leicht sein aber diese
antikörper spielen offen da bei dieser
ersten reaktion werde ich nochmal kann
eine riesenrolle und daher kann man
quasi also die uhr danach stellen wann
mehrere menschen sich infizieren werden
dass es einfach also eine also an das
ist ein verfall dieser zellen und also
die ältesten sind zuerst dran aber
ehrlich gesagt werden alle doppelt
geimpften irgendwann so niedrige
antikörpertiter oder also wie sagt man
spiegel spiegel haben also dass man sich
wieder infizieren kann und dann ist der
unterschied zwischen den jüngeren und
den älteren nur der folgende die
jüngeren erkranken dann nicht so schwer
die älteren erkranken sehr schwer und
zum beispiel eine studie aus den
vereinigten staaten mit also früheren
soldaten weiteren skaterbahn genau da
war hat sehr viel diva denn die
amerikaner haben früh geimpft die
werte lassen sich gerne im ehemaligen
soldaten sie sind sofort bereit den arm
hin zu halten haben sich früher impfen
lassen ist eine ganze zahl und her waren
gute eben dafür war zum teil der
stärkste im stoff dabei von moderner und
trotzdem sind von denen doch jetzt
einige gestorben weil der impfstoff das
nicht mehr halten konnte daher ist die
schnelle booster impfung das wichtigste
was wir jetzt tun können um die eltern
schon wieder bei der impfung bei uns ist
der ganze abend minister
geschäftsführend herr braun sie haben
ich habe das in der anmoderation gesagt
natürlich auch nicht nur zur kenntnis
genommen sondern sie wissen dass auch
die bundeskanzlerin mit der situation
jetzt sehr unzufrieden ist traurig zu
sein reicht ja nicht aus wie groß ist
die gefahr dass wir tatsächlich wieder
die die wir am meisten schützen wollten
und um die wir uns am meisten sorgen
wollten weil sie am schwersten
erkrankten können nicht hinreichend
schützen weil wir nicht schnell genug
sind also das ist dieses jahr noch
ärgerlicher als im letzten damals haben
uns teilweise ja noch die mittel wie zum
beispiel die impfung gefehlt jetzt haben
wir alle mittel und die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hat auch
schon ende august anfang september
gesagt dass wir bei den hochbetagten
diese booster impfung machen wollen die
auffrischung und dass es hier zu
schleppend beginnt ist wirklich ein ganz
großer schaden das sehen wir das führt
zu unnötigen todesfällen und deshalb es
ist ganz dringend das wird auch zwischen
bund und ländern darüber nochmal reden
wie wir das organisatorisch verbessern
weil die möglichkeiten sind alle da es
geht um gute augen
überhaupt noch mal ein obwohl es eben
eigentlich schon ein bisschen später es
ist nicht ein bisschen spät
bundeskanzlerin ist im
amt er bis anfang dezember und hat die
volle verantwortung
unser land wie die ganze bundesregierung
die nehmen wir auch war hier ist gefahr
im verzug dass kein neues politisches
projekt der nächsten legislatur meint es
gar nicht so man hat es eben
zwischendurch september/oktober das
gefühl oder schon auch im august meine
könnte durchaus ein bisschen häufiger
sich auch mit der krone politik befassen
aber da waren wir herr pusch in der
situation chef des landkreises heinsberg
das irgendwie die bevölkerung zwischen
zwei regierungen geraten ist und
eigentlich 23 monat der aufklärung
dieser art nicht statt hören also ich
glaube das ist ein generelles problem
der kommunikation aber auch der
aufgabenverteilung zwischen bund und
ländern also ich habe bis heute nicht
verstanden warum man eigentlich nicht in
so einer nationalen notlage sagt wir
brauchen eine art bundes krisenstab ja
wir haben keine probleme damit gehabt
dass die parlamente der exekutive die
komplette verantwortung für übertragen
haben warum haben wir dann ein problem
damit gehabt dass man bundes krisenstab
gegründet wo dann die exekutiven
zusammenkommen beraten erst mal
ermitteln wie ist die lage dann beraten
fachleute hinzuziehen und dann
entscheiden aber mit einer stimme
sprechen und eine entscheidung aus
bringen diese ganze kakophonie von
unterschiedlichen stimmungen von
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
dergleichen sind ja eigentlich keine
gremien die aus meiner sicht in
irgendeiner form krisentauglich sind
also ein krisenstab hat eine klare
arbeitsablauf er hat eine klare aufgabe
die hat ein klares korsett und man wird
gezwungen und diszipliniert sich auch an
dieses korsett zu halten und dann sind
diese ganzen
missverständnis oder diese ganzen ist
beispielsweise passiert dass jemand aus
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ausgegangen ist und gesagt wir machen
das jetzt und dann guckt man sich
gegenseitig an und sagt ja wer macht
eigentlich das habe ich gar nicht so
genau festgelegt ist normal das thema
impfen ja also testen testen und besser
gesagt es wird getestet ab nächster
woche ja wer macht es eigentlich ja die
test besorgt der bund ja aber ihr macht
das doch jetzt ihre länder also das wird
in einem normalen krisenstabs modus den
man auch mal eingeübt hat nie passieren
weil dann klar die aufgaben verteilt
sind klar ist wer das macht und die
kommunikation läuft an einer stelle
zentral also das ist natürlich
vielleicht auch ein zeichen unserer
demokratie unsere staatsform aber ich
habe das bis heute nicht verstanden
warum man sich nicht wirklich mal in dem
krisenstaat modus diszipliniert bei so
einer krise solchen nationalen ausmaß
ist so ich wollte noch mal besonders
nach diesem ist ein guter punkt ich
wollte noch einmal besonders nach dieser
zeit jetzt im sommer bis eigentlich
jetzt fragen herr braun weil man ja auch
beispielsweise von dem rk ii noch vor
drei wochen gehört hat das doppelt
geimpfte menschen höheren alters ein
moderates risiko haben und darauf hat
sich dann auch der gesundheitsminister
berufen wie kann sowas sein also ich
glaube dass rk ii hat nie einen hehl
daraus gemacht dass der winter sehr
schwierig werden kann und wir haben ja
immer gesehen dass aufgrund der delta
variante wenn man die zahlen vergleicht
mit dem vorjahr die anzeichen sind den
ganzen sommer über schon so dass delta
uns mehr probleme macht als der wildtyp
im letzten jahr und das auch die
impfquote die wir bisher erreicht haben
uns davor keinen effektiven schutz gibt
und das hat das lka auch immer deutlich
gesagt und deshalb kann ich auch nur
sagen wir haben viele notwendige
beschlüsse das ständige testen ist auch
teil dieser mpk beschlüsse und wenn ich
dann jetzt teilweise von diesen von
ihnen zitierten fällen höhere dass man
sagt man will dann jetzt wieder stärker
testen in der pflegeeinrichtung dann
muss ich sagen ich bin jetzt dafür dass
wir das gesetzlich vorschreiben
weil ich eigentlich davon ausgegangen
bin dass getestet wird das ist so
entscheidend also teilweise ist die
situation zu leicht genommen worden
deshalb müssen wir jetzt sehr schnell
konsequentes testen die möglichkeit an
allen besuchern von den bewohnern und
nett und das wird auch weiterhin
kostenlos eines wird vom koblenzer halt
das muss konsequent erfolgen und das
angebot eine auffrischimpfung zu
bekommen muss auch sehr zügig erfolgen
überall da wo das noch nicht der fall so
wir reden gleich nochmal über den
eindruck den die politik der gemacht hat
auch der gesundheitsminister wichtig ist
nur um jetzt auch noch mal an der
jetzigen situation dranzubleiben herr
gassen darauf zu verweisen dass wir bei
diesem fall beispielsweise da in
brandenburg feststellen dass 50 prozent
der pflegenden nicht geimpft sind warum
eigentlich in so einer situation jetzt
nicht festlegen dass es für die diesen
unmittelbaren kontakt zum patienten oder
eben zum bewohner haben nicht geben muss
neben pflicht ist eine politische
entscheidung das ist keine medizinische
natürlich ist es für mich
selbstverständlich dass wenig
patientenkontakte dass ich geimpft bin
in meiner praxis ist auch jeder
mitarbeiter und jeder kollege geimpft
und es ist glaube ich auch eine ein
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem wenn wir wir
brauchen das ankündigt sollen wir machen
eine testpflicht für besucher im
pflegeheim die vielleicht doppelt gegen
die müssen sich dann testen das wenn sie
ihre angehörigen besuchen und dann
arbeitet die hälfte der belegschaft
ungeimpfte also das ist glaube ich sehr
schwierig auszuhalten ob man das mit
einer impfpflicht regelt man darf
sicherlich nicht völlig unterschätzen
dass wir ohnehin eine pflegekraft mangel
haben also da nichts zu riskieren dass
ein teil dann gar nicht mehr zur arbeit
kommt ich mache das für eine schwierige
entscheidung aber ich teile ihr
unverständnis dass man in eine
medizinische pflegendem beruf wo doch
eine auch ein gefährte des patienten gut
vorhanden ist da ungeimpft zu agieren
muss man doch irgendwann entscheiden
herr lauterbach sie haben sich auch
immer gegen eine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen nochmal die gesonderte
impfpflicht für
pflegendes personal in den altenheimen
in den krankenhäusern muss ist die nicht
längst geben wenn man vermeiden möchte
das sehr gefährdete auf infekt züge
treffen zunächst einmal stimme ich an
gassen zu kontakt zu patienten wenn man
nicht games ist dass das normalerweise
nicht geben und eine krankenhäusern ist
es so auf der grundlage dessen was wir
bei erhebungen also
herausgefunden haben da sind
wahrscheinlich mehr als 90 prozent der
pflegekräfte auch geimpft das heißt wir
haben ein spezielles problem tatsächlich
hier in der altenpflege und das könnte
hier auch so sagen dass das nicht
unbedingt die pflegekräfte selbst sind
sondern die sogenannten hilfskräfte das
ist zumindest was ich also bisher in
erfahrung bringen konnte wie kann man
dem begegnen
also ich kenne herrn brown zu gebrauchen
eine verbindliche regelung dass in der
pflegeeinrichtung jeder getestet wird
dort arbeitet oder besucht das muss für
die besucher gelten das muss für
diejenigen gelten die also dort arbeiten
und da mittlerweile auch durchbruch
infektionen möglich sind bei denjenigen
die geimpft sind also muss ich hier auf
nummer sicher gehen in der zeit die also
wir noch haben um die booster impfung zu
machen daher wäre man pragmatischer
vorschlag das ist eine verbindliche
regelung gibt dass jeder der in einer
pflegeeinrichtung arbeitet und jeder der
besucher dokumentieren muss dass er
gegen das er getestet
kostenlose test das muss dokumentiert
werden ich sage mit unterschrift und
wenn es betrug gibt dann haben wir die
sanktionen sie haben eben nach einem
gesetz
also verlangt dieses gesetz haben wir
werden sie hier sich eintragen
ausgetestet sie sind es aber nicht dann
ist das ein gefährlicher betrug und das
würde natürlich dann auch das strafrecht
zufolge bringen somit also eine solche
regelung jährlich für
gänzlich weil ich kann mich nicht auf
die pflegekräfte allein konzentrieren
ich muss auch die besucher testen wir
sind jetzt in einer so empfindlichen
lage das eigentlich jeden tag jeder
besucher und jeder mitarbeiter denen
eine pflegeeinrichtung kommt
getestet und unterschreibt dass die
testung stattgefunden so jetzt geben wir
hier auch weil dieser sendung zum
beispiel wir sitzen hier alle sicher
geimpft und getestet und in der
pflegeeinrichtung passiert nicht das ist
nicht richtig und das muss kontrolliert
werden auch darüber reden wir gleich
noch frage an frau falk die franzosen
beispielsweise sagen wer in diesem
bereich arbeitet und nicht geimpft ist
arbeitet nicht also es ist keine gut
formulierte frage sie rücken sich das zu
recht wer sich nicht impft und mit zu
betreuenden alten oder kranken
hantiert und für sie da ist kann seinen
beruf nicht weiter ausüben ist es hart
aber gerecht und fair und vor allen
dingen ziel führen es ist natürlich wie
herr lauterbach gerade gesagt hat auch
herr braun eine politische frage aber
die viel wichtigere sozusagen die
wahrnehmung wie gefährlich das ist dass
es eigentlich glaube ich das
kommunikations element ist wir brauchen
und wenn sie einmal noch mal mehr
erlauben kurz auf herrn lauterbacher
einzugehen das klingt jetzt ein bisschen
so als ob die impfung nicht reicht und
weil wir die in weil die impfung nicht
reicht haben wir jetzt diese situation
das ist übrigens nicht so sondern im
juli hat srk ihren hervorragenden
bericht herausgegeben der heißt
vorbereitung auf herbst winter der ist
so ein bisschen glaube ich im wahlkampf
untergegangen da stand klar
genau da gab es eine abbildung verdi
einmal verinnerlicht hat war
elektrisiert wenn wir es nicht schaffen
über 75% geimpfte doppelt geimpfte in
der bevölkerung zu kommen haben wir
darunter ein risiko dass die zahlen
ansteigen das ist genau das liefern
modellierungen von das waren
modellrechnungen wo man sehr schön sehen
könnte über 75 es ist deutlich einfacher
die zahlen zu senken und wir haben ja
ein immunologisches gedächtnis
lauterbach gott sei dank das manchmal
besser als das gedächtnis im köpfchen
und da ist es tatsächlich so dass das
immunologische gedächtnis ist so gut
dass es sich wieder erinnert dass wir
schon geimpft worden auch wenn die
antikörper runtergehen warum ich das
sage ist die impfung ist sehr gut und
das gedächtnis ist sehr gut der druck
den wir jetzt haben das risiko für die
älteren menschen kommt durch die hohen
zahlen und wenn wir es schaffen würden
die zahlen wieder herunter zu bringen
dann sinkt das risiko deutlich für
gerade diese vokabel in gruppen und wenn
wir jetzt nicht gegensteuern danach
werden wir sehr schwer haben wirklich zu
erreichen dass wir die schützen können
und dann kommt die diskussion brauchen
wir gesetze für menschen die nicht
geimpft sind für mir wäre es lieber wir
würden begreifen wie wichtig das eigene
handeln ist wie wichtig es ist dass wir
die paar prozent über die 75 wenigsten
schaffen und dann können wir uns darüber
unterhalten ob man vielleicht bevor man
gesetzliche vorgaben hat ich bin ja
keine juristin sondern biologin ob man
nicht kreativer damit umgeht wer wie
arbeitet und den kontakt reduziert und
das testen verpflichtet und das versucht
den menschen klar zu machen dass ihr
handeln verantwortung beinhaltet und
dass wir daran appellieren versuch wäre
es vielleicht so und wissen wir denn
also das ist ja auch was wir hier schon
besprochen haben verfolgt wissen wir
denn wirklich dass diese 75 prozent mit
unserer im quote nicht erreicht werden
also auch da musste sich das lka
korrigieren auch da wissen wir
eigentlich immer noch nicht so richtig
ob wenigstens die doppelt geimpfte zahl
stimmt und ob eigentlich auch die
genesene dar eingerechnet ist aber da
nicken sie jetzt und sind einigermaßen
sicher also dass es noch nicht schaffen
das lka hat klar gesagt die zahlen die
gemeldet wurden sind die die heute um 19
uhr wurde der wochenbericht
veröffentlicht die wir alle immer
angucken und sehen wie die zahlen sich
verändern maximal fünf prozent sind die
laut lka aussagen da kann man sich
glaube ich auch sehr gut drauf verlassen
die von den hausärztinnen und hausärzten
und den betriebsarzt praxen gekommen
sind und mehr als fünf prozent zins
nicht das heißt wir erreichen in der
gesamtbevölkerung dann vielleicht gerade
weil es mir aber 80 vorgesehen aber wir
dürfen die kinder nicht vergessen und
heute hat man wie
die höchste instanz ist doch bei den
zehn- bis 14-jährigen wir müssen ob die
mitdenken ja die intelligenz der
infektion also die gesamtbevölkerung im
blick ist glaube ich wichtig herr busch
impfpflicht die sehr sagen die menschen
bei ihnen in den medizinischen
einrichtungen in den pflegeeinrichtungen
fürsorgepflicht wenn wir unsere mama
unseren papa hier bei ihnen in der
residenz haben dann möchten wir
sichergehen dass sie sich hier nicht
infiziert mal unabhängig
und ja ständig um den heißen brei herum
also wir suchen das ersatzlösungen dafür
dass man da vielleicht die politische
entscheidung war trifft wir führen im
pflicht für pflegepersonal in
altenheimen
ja ich weiß gar nicht warum man sich da
so schwer mit tut frage ich gerade also
das ist alles scheint irgendwie so ein
mantra was man irgendwann festgelegt hat
wir sind gegen jede impfpflicht aber das
muss man differenzieren auch juristisch
differenzieren wenn ich einen 20
jährigen der von den schweren
krankheitsverlauf vielleicht gar nicht
betroffen ist und dass vielleicht auch
guten gewissens
annimmt eine impfpflicht auferlege ist
dass im rahmen der verhältnismässigkeit
eine ganz andere geschichte also wenn
ich jemanden haben der jeden tag mit
alten menschen zusammenkommt von alten
mensch zu alten mensch geht ganz nah den
kommt die pflegen muss da kann ich
verlangen dass der sich impfen lässt und
dass hier findet auch das kann man auch
durchaus da muss man auch als politik
mal mutig sein das kann man durch auch
festlegen genau so sollte man vielleicht
auch mal mutig sein sie haben eben
gesagt die einschätzung war noch eine
andere wir dürfen alle mal zu geben dass
im rahmen der pandemie über die ganzen
jahre die selbst stattfindet durchaus
auch mal jedoch da also ich bin so
erstaunt über die diskussion jetzt weil
ich in der ersten phase vom rk ii die
vorgabe bekommen habe jeder der
kontaktperson erster kategorie ist der
geht in zweiwöchiges berufsausübung
verbot das hat damals zu deren situation
geführt dass ich gesagt habe leute wenn
ich die alle jetzt in quarantäne steht
habe ich keinen mehr im krankenhaus habe
ich keinen kinderarzt mehr da hab ich
gar keine mehr da ein paar wochen später
als das rk ii das gericht hat gesagt das
geht tatsächlich in der praxis nicht die
durften dann sogar weiterarbeiten wenn
die infiziert waren unter schutzkleidung
ja da war das ein riesenproblem dass
jemand der nur kontaktperson ist dennoch
nicht mal irgendwas im tomate weiter
heute heute lassen wir es zu dass leute
die ungeimpft sind ja und dadurch nicht
wesentlich höheres risiko gerade in dem
bereich darstellen weiter arbeit okay
wir brauchen helfen sie politische
entscheidung haben wir gerade verstanden
es macht überhaupt gar keinen
biologischen nutzung im gegenteil es hat
einen großen schaden wenn menschen
ungeimpft auf eine honorable und wohlrab
lockrufe treffen warum gibt es keine
impfpflicht in deutschland warum machen
wir nicht wie die franzosen oder wie die
italiener wenigstens in diesen berufen
wir haben also dass das wesentliche
argument hat der gast schon genannt die
große sorge ist wir haben schon pflege
problem in der altenpflege da sind schon
zu wenige und ein teil wird sich dann
vielleicht impfen lassen und ein teil
wird es eben nicht tun und wird dann
woanders arbeiten wird vielleicht den
heimatland zurück gehen es gibt
verschiedene also die die einrichtungen
sagen uns macht es bitte auf gar keinen
fall juristisch ist es so dass wir das
grundproblem dass es dass es
immungeschwächte patienten gibt gibt es
schon immer bisher haben wir auch in
anderen bereichen dieses argument noch
nie zur grundlage einer impfpflicht
gemacht wer immer nur einen aus
rettungsversuch der whu für einen keim
wie wir das zum beispiel bei den masern
gesehen haben und dann ist ja trotzdem
die frage dass wir
wie viel zeit eigentlich noch haben das
aufzuholen oder zuzulassen also man
stellt sich ja vor die dinge geschehen
simultan die menschen begegnen einander
es gibt immer noch einen zu hohen anteil
von ungeimpften wir müssten eigentlich
wie viele menschen noch impfen damit wir
die bei der erstimpfung dabei haben drei
millionen über 60 wird immer gesagt sind
noch nicht mal erst geimpft wie viel
sind es insgesamt ich glaube auch eben
15 erwachsene müssten wir also das ist
das sehr ärgerlich dass wir die sich
impfen lassen würden wäre der winter
entspannt ist nicht mal klar sagen und
weil die sich aber nicht impfen lassen
drücken wir jetzt die anderen in den in
den booster oder sagen sie nein denn
diese brauchen alle und booster brauchen
die alten sowieso
auffrischimpfung für mich klingt auch
freundlich als booster und
heute hat ja ist ja auch darüber
gesprochen worden auch in den jüngeren
jahrgängen um auch diese verbreitung des
virus
stärker aufzuhalten auch nach den
erfahrungen ja in israel dass wir
generell dem booster auch öffnen für
weitere gruppen damit wir einfach die
zahlen runter kriegen weil in der tat
wenn ich ein alter ein älterer mensch
bin eine impfung lässt langsam nach ist
eher die frage wie häufig begegne ich
eigentlich dem risiko sich zu infizieren
und das kann man in den letzten tagen
regelrecht spüren wir haben extrem hohe
zahlen sowohl zahlen hatten wir noch nie
und wir haben auch eine extrem hohe test
positiven rate das heißt meine vermutung
dass die wahren infektionsfälle höher
sind als das was wir gerade an den
infektionszahlen sehen ist leider so gut
dass über das nicht genau wissen es
erfolg davon dass wir das testen jetzt
als keule benutzt haben um die
ungeimpften zu zwingen sich jetzt impfen
zu lassen
tatsächlich in der rua da sind wir noch
mal beim testen hier test regime
festlegen politisch festlegen herr
lauterbach sie haben immer gesagt wir
sollten für die ungeimpften die tests
bezahlbar machen damit es einen druck
gibt auf die so richtig gut für die
pandemie ist es nicht das bestreite ich
also wir haben ein anderes problem also
zunächst einmal diejenigen die hier
glauben dass es gut ist den druck auf
die ungeimpften auszulösen indem die die
tests bezahlen sollen aber die gehen
dann einfach gar nicht mehr zum test es
gibt ja hier zwei also bewegungen die
die also zu beachten sind zum einen
diejenigen die jetzt ungeimpft sind und
die tests selbst bezahlen müssen sind
eher geneigt sich impfen zu lassen weil
sie dann die tests nicht mehr brauchen
12 und ich hatte über uns daher immer
vorgeschlagen dass man die impfung
anbietet in den testzentren dann kann
derjenige der sich testen lässt gleich
überlegen lasse ich mich jetzt zum
fünften mal testen oder mache ich die
impfung und der zweite punkt ist der
also selbst wenn es so ist dass
diejenigen die also sagen wir jetzt
ungehemmt sind und die tests eigentlich
bräuchten die tests nicht bezahlen
wollen sagen die tests sind mir zu teuer
ich mache das nicht wenn dann richtig
kontrolliert wurde dann könnten die
ungeimpften und ungetesteten in viele
veranstaltungen und auch in vielen
restaurants cafés und dergleichen nicht
rein das heißt ihre kontakte würden
reduziert anders ausgedrückt das ist
auch eine maßnahme zur reduktion der
kontakte der ungeimpften und die
ungeimpften da ist wir brauchen ja
völlig recht das sind ja diejenigen die
im moment die panne mit treiben wenn man
diese hohen instanzen sich mal anschaut
und rechnet die nach vorne also es gibt
heute zum beispiel wieder eine gut
gemachte modellierung für das dc und da
wird man eine garantie frigge ist
intensiv register genau und da ist die
projektion das bis januar die also
incident steigern wird auf mindestens
250 bis zu 400 also deutlich über das
ist eine konservative modellierung das
bezieht sich aber alles auf die kleine
gruppe der umgehen finden dann muss man
überlegen wie hoch dann dort tatsächlich
die instanzen sind das sind anja
incident und in der gruppe der umkämpfen
von weit über 1000 das heißt die
ungeimpften gehen jetzt im moment voll
ins risiko hinein die wir tragen das
maximale risiko und ich glaube wir sind
schlecht darin zu kommunizieren wie hoch
das risiko für die ungeimpften derzeit
ist und auch wie viele von den
ungeimpften
bleibende schäden wegtragen müssen
berichtet entweder oder einen schweren
verlauf wir wissen dass drei millionen
der über 65-jährigen also ungeimpfte
sind das sind ja menschen die gehen voll
ins risiko ich glaube dass das diese
diese dramatik das wird aus meiner sicht
viel zu wenig also besprochen naja bin
ein großer freund dass man meint die
inzidenz von den geimpften und
ungeimpften getrennt da spreche all
diese 170 diverse etwa haben heißt
ungefähr incident von 50 bei denjenigen
die wm zu sind und 450 bei denen die
nicht geimpft das würde auch die dinge
besser bewusst machen und dennoch noch
mal die frage wir haben es hier und da
schon anklingen lassen hat es vielleicht
auch hat unsere situation jetzt
vielleicht auch etwas damit zu tun dass
wir vor elf tagen noch einen
bundesgesundheitsminister hörten der das
sagte
die epidemische lage der ausnahmezustand
vom bundestag festgestellt der kann aus
meiner sicht beendet werden weil vier
von fünf erwachsene geimpft sind die
pandemie ist alles andere als vorbei
wenn auch äußerungen von mir so
verstanden werden konnten dann war ich
nicht klar genug das sage ich auch
selbstkritisch zu und ergänzte im mitte
oktober noch dass das robert koch
institut das risiko für geimpfte
personen als moderat einstuft und dass
man so mit angesichts der aktuellen
impfquote die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite einschränken könne
herr pusch wenn man möchte dass die
leute bei der stange bleiben
kommuniziert man dann also wenn man
möchte dass die leute bei der stange
bleiben dann muss man sich erstmal
bemühen denke ich mal
dieses diese polarisierung die ja in der
in der wortwahl in der politik stellen
die stadt findet man runter zu fahren
und versuchen möglichst viele leute
mitzunehmen ja also wir hatten doch bis
vor ein paar wochen auch die situation
das klang ja gerade so ein bisschen an
da wurde ja den kämpfen erzählt für euch
die pandemie eigentlich vorbei ich kann
noch an schlagzeilen mich erinnern wir
haben jetzt nur noch eine pandemie die
ungeimpften das hat den einen das gefühl
vermittelt was ja auch nicht so ganz
stimmt für euch ist die pandemie vorbei
das kommt ja auch ein bisschen drüber
wenn der spanier an sagt
epidemiologischen lage ist zu ende das
heißt sie sind super sorglos und haben
für dich das abgehakt was er menschlich
ist und die anderen waren die bösen und
weil die dann halt das schuld sind das
ist weiter läuft hat man gesagt okay wir
können sie ja nicht zwingen sich impfen
zu lassen das haben wir immer gesagt
aber dann machen wir den das leben so
schwer wie möglich dann bauen wir die
kostenlosen test ab und und und
damit hat man eigentlich aus meiner
sicht das was jetzt hier spekuliert wird
nämlich wie viele von denen sind
eigentlich tatsächlich infiziert usw
damit hat man sich eigentlich selber
abgeschaltet man hat eine maßnahme die
wir im frühjahr noch super propagiert
haben nach dem motto testen testen
testen so viel wie möglich wenn andere
möglichkeit das infektionsgeschehen und
dann ist immer noch nicht klar
irgendwo annähern einzugrenzen habe ich
ja gar nicht und da haben wir ja sogar
gesagt wir machen drei gehen denn die
leute sollen ja ein anreiz haben sich
testen zu lassen die dürfen damit was
machen die dürfen dann irgendwo rein
jetzt genommen deswegen finde ich auch
diese zweig geschichte jetzt einerseits
nachvollziehbar lauterbach andererseits
aber wenn ich will dass möglichst viele
leute sich testen lassen total
kontraproduktiv
mit dem test nichts mehr dürfen wenn die
nur mehr hin dürfen damit ja dann wird
sich auch keiner testen lassen ob die
kostenlos sind oder nicht haben wenn sie
irgendwo hingehen dann gefährden sie
doch auch niemanden
tun immer genau da sie haben doch gerade
selber gesagt ich war heute hier in
berlin mit essen heute mittag ja hab ich
kein mensch nach meinem impfausweis
kommentar sonst können das ist aber ein
riesen skandal dass das gehört das ist
doch die reaktion der leute dann auch
dann jede regel sind das ist nicht die
reaktion darauf sondern das ist eine
vollkommen inakzeptable also lachse
umgehens weise mit unseren regeln das
muss man sagen also das jetzt aber
entschuldigung wir sind jetzt schon
wieder bei den tests gelandet ich
versuche noch mal bei diesem punkt zu
bleiben ich verstehe dass sie bei den
tests landen wollen aber ich möchte
gerne noch mal verstehen dass wir
politisch eigentlich für botschaften
ausgesandt haben frau fall helfen sie zu
ordnen wir haben erst gesagt super sache
vier von fünf erwachsenen sind geimpft
wir können diese lage wie sie abgekürzt
genannt wird jetzt zu ende november
auslaufen lassen und jetzt sagen wir wir
sind in einer ganz schweren phase der
pandemie wir müssen die alten
superschnell boostern und eigentlich
müssen wir alle boostern so also das
passiert innerhalb von drei wochen unter
berufung auf das robert koch institut
wer soll da mit kommen also es ist
kompliziert das ist unglaublich wie mal
ein bisschen zu ordnen also die eine
geschichte ist die politische seite und
es ist für mich zum beispiel wäre eine
frage an herrn braun von meiner seite
wir haben ja in allen bundesländern sehr
gute corona verordnungen jemanden super
nachlesen kann der sind die warnstufen
sehr gut und transparent das ist ja das
eine was man ja schon als richtlinie als
normaler bürger sich angucken kann und
bürgerinnen und sich überlegen kann wie
verhalte ich mich ich würde gerne wissen
ob die erhalten bleiben weil ich
sozusagen da dies ist die frage was
passiert
wenn die epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite ausläuft was aber besonders
wichtig ist dass eben diese diese dass
die möglichkeit ist misszuverstehen weil
leider sehr groß dass es eben nicht
bedeutet dass wir schon so viele
menschen geimpft haben dass wir
gefahrlos mehr kontakte zu lassen können
weil nämlich sonst die instanzen steigen
also insofern war es nicht überraschend
und das robert-koch-institut hat
wirklich immer darauf hingewiesen aber
es ist schon so man hört es natürlich
nicht so gerne und ich glaube die
kommunikation war an der stelle auch
wieder einen punkt wo man überlegen kann
es ist ein unterschied zu sagen die
partie ist zu ende das war ja nicht der
fall das haben auch alle
fachgesellschaften gleich gesagt bitte
nicht missverstehen was politisch
passiert ist die eine seite was er mit
den infizierten passiert können wir
jeden tag sehen wenn die zahlen steigen
steigen die und dann haben die natürlich
einen effekt auf die frage wie ist der
druck auf die geimpften auf die impf
durchbrüche und deswegen ist glaube ich
die kommunikation noch mal ganz wichtig
zu sagen wir haben noch nicht den
schutzwall den wir haben müssen man kann
sich das vielleicht als als damm
vorstellen als schutzwall und jetzt
kommt die vierte welle und der ist noch
nicht hoch genug dass wir vor allem auch
die wohl arabien gruppen wirklich
schützen kann deswegen müssen wir den
damm normal wir müssen den